good there's a delicious Christmas tree
[Applause]
hey guys so it's Christmas month yeah so
it's freezing oh my god why am I in a
t-shirt I've actually never celebrated
Christmas before because I'm Jewish we
celebrate Hanukkah long-lasting oil baby
but then I realized we work at BuzzFeed
where 90% of our titles are retried
blank so let's go try Christmas it's the
most wonderful time of the year for some
but for others it's just another day
looking at you Jewish people I don't
care if you love the correct Lord or not
I just can't I just care that you spread
joy Keith is gonna be educating us on
some Christmas stuff the thing that
upsets me about Christmas is it's just
so goddamn imposing like Halloween is
the best holiday of all time and
Halloween knows how to stay in its month
you can hate Christmas but you'd be
wrong I don't know what my opinion on
Christmas is I don't really have one but
for me I think I just got so good at
being Jewish I was like you know what I
need to get good at Christmas Chris is a
fake you put a tree in your house come
on I've heard it's the most magical time
of the year I don't buy it
Zach you're really bringing me down so I
want you to get out there I want you to
make these trees look good I want you
sing those carols loud and proud I
needed to get out there get your friends
gifts and most importantly I need you to
sit on Santa's lap like you never sat on
nobody's lap befo I figured out a young
age that Santa wasn't real and I don't
appreciate being lied to
okay let's teach my Jewish colleagues
how to do Christmas right hi Keith hey
lovely thank you very festive there's a
little candle right this little light of
mine I'm gonna let it shine part of the
joy of Christmas is look it's super
stupid so I got you all some cute little
tree buddies now how cute is that
should we rip off the tag or keep or
return this you spend $50 on this
[ __ ] well the company did oh you
know we've you know to get us really
going how about a toast
burn some rum Eric can't drink that I
know
Zach I already know that finer I have a
Virgin Mary knock I have a alcoholic
almond dog for you Zach
lion the hi I'm oh goodness what you
think that is incredible it's like a
like a sweet melted dessert and I can
see how this would get you drunk without
realizing you're tasting a little bit of
the season but now I can't walk you
through everything so I need you to go
out and do a lot of this on your own
okay but here's the no don't leave us I
know you guys are some [ __ ] goofballs
you're gonna come in here and try your
best to represent my holiday I want to
take it serious
I want the tree to look like a tree but
you'd want to wake up at 6:00 a.m. run
down and your pajamas and sit around and
tear open present I want to hear you
guys sing follow lalala so you brains
fall out and bring each other
joy Thank You Keith you're welcome
bye Merry Christmas at eggnog need a
break yeah I knew Keith was gonna make
us decorate a tree
I brought some props I really want to
educate Keith on like how good Jews are
at decorating trees I got some
decorations yes let's make you this our
own all right I got bagels and I got the
jelly-filled doughnuts what are they
called
I have no idea well would you see
jelly-filled oh yeah we love doughnuts
what else you got
oh okay I got this wait wait let me go
get it you start decorating ah that's
really bad actually
well here's my ideas I'm just gonna just
would stay oh all right I'm gonna try
one of these jelly doughnuts you can
just you can check it in I love shoving
it in should we've gotten some blocks to
put on it and we should just gotten some
blocks to eat
oh good there's a delicious Christmas
tree we're gonna innovate all over your
holiday Jews can do Christmas better
than y'all way better yeah that's right
we said it check it out ready I got the
best ending for it keep welcome tree we
did this look at what these two dragons
bill it's not the worst trip ever say
Anna try it I mean it's a good tone at
home I mean this is very funny and cute
I would like a little Donuts in the back
you're not telling the world anything
about your Christmas we're telling them
that we don't care about that yeah it's
not the message you want to send it Oh
Christmas is about caring about
everybody Oh God inviting people in
holding hands you hold hands around a
tree
no but you hold hands don't yell you've
been Jude we need someone to lift the
tree on a chair no that doesn't make any
sense you got to take the Christmas out
there maybe some caroling around the
office we have to find the Carol no no
you know that's stupid you're being
stupid
a classic Christmas Carol deck the halls
I think I know it
deck the halls falala no just being
stupid people are gonna leave the video
you're not taking this seriously the
song goes deck the halls with boughs of
holly fa la la la la la yeah go go
around the office bring some joy I am
very bad at singing I I actually got
kicked out of my choir wow you're bad I
feel like a jackass like people are
working hard we're bringing them joy you
think that's what we're gonna be we're
gonna bring joy
now follow lies there's a significance
there I mean I just [ __ ] lalala hooray
we're having fun
for the ancient you think of it like a
spongebob type moment strike the harp
and join the chorus ooh boy
ooh tough crowd you're in New York City
this city has one of the most iconic
Christmas trees and it's a little
skating rink under that tree there's a
big lighting ceremony this is like the
Christmas city of America go out
experience it so we're here at the
Christmas mark it's not Christmas unless
we buy a bunch of stuff that people
don't need so let's go out there and buy
stuff for our friends and our loved ones
[Music]
[Music]
I like buying myself tip I agree with
that yeah it's way less stressful as you
know you're gonna love it I know what I
want Jesus look at that realistic baby
oh so I did it I bought a gift I don't
know who the gift is for worst case
scenario also these look pretty
delicious maybe they'll just be a treat
myself gift I just got a mini Australian
Shepherd his name is Bowie and the
inside of it looks just like him
i co-own him so I got these sacks for
Bowie's mother oh dude I'm really
slacking on the gifts yeah I've got two
gifts I'm crushed Zac you gotta help me
what do I get
you have a girlfriend I know there are
some jewelry what kind of jewelry does
she like me she likes rings I've been
here before and she decided not to get
it that's perfect because you know that
she wants it and for the surprise are
didn't sure that you remember her I was
not full Wow Wow
there's a line you're a real Mensch I'm
such a mensch it's it's like right
around here I remember I walked in oh
it's right here ring you got this man
you got this you texting or texting no
you can't know what it's not gonna be
like I'm Ted I'm trying to do a secret
text what could you possibly texted I
said hey what's the ring that you liked
by the way I'm not buying it for you
surprise what that doesn't work no that
one is this yeah oh they're both really
cool actually
these are the two yeah step both hey
that was delightful not at all stressful
Eric you did it it was extremely
stressful Christmas there's a totally
non-religious figure who's really the
figure of Christmas Santa Claus you guys
gotta go your photo taken the Santa
Claus wait you got the real Santa here
yeah oh oh oh look who's here it's Eric
the elf
I'm your elf yeah you could be my ELF
that's for me I'm Jewish so I do you're
Jewish yeah get out of here
yeah I'm Jewish reality Santa's Jewish
saddle Sandler's Jewish toque you're
Jewish yes Santa's Jewish wait I'm sorry
what there's no in fact no no
so many Jews I know orange juice so what
do you think about you celebrating
Christmas this universal look at the
Lovejoy look at all the beauty oh my god
your lap is so soft oh my god Oh
body by his wife Phyllis who still says
my wife she feeds me well now you think
I got this wonderful body way to feel it
is that the name of saying his wife yeah
get out of here okay well they did it
kind of that was really fun I got to
experience so many things today I met
Santa my face touched his beard like
that was one of the most incredible
moments of my life probably I got some
presents for my friends and you know
what it felt good Christmas is about
being with your loved ones and having
fun you don't have to care about the
baby Jesus but if you do bonus points of
course I get it or get it it's a magical
holiday it's a magical time it's hard to
resist its it's infectious and the
coolest thing for me was I got to like
make some friends I met Zach and Keith
in the Christmas spirit I just wanted to
give you guys a gift for being in the
video
I got a spread ship necklaces and it's a
s'more it's got a Mardi Belle and
someone can take the little graham
cracker and someone can take chocolate
and says best friends for every heir get
so tangled how do you never be friends
no friends are supposed to wear it like
this like this know that it's you're
truly a best friend
[Music]
mr. everybody can celebrate Christmas
you know ultimately it's a all the
rituals or pagan thing that we Sol and
then the rest of its commercialism so
just [ __ ] go nuts baby it's Christmas
no you know I'm saying I don't forgot it
on camera but Santa called himself a
chick magnet that was weird